j'ai prié nos collègues d'accepter nos
excuses pour ce retard lié à
l'entretien que le premier ministre a
souhaité avoir en votre présence avec le
président du sénat et moi-même pour
l'informer d'un certain nombre
d'orientations qui vont être prises
demain par le président de la république
et tout le monde comprendra ici qu'on
laisse au président de la république
la priorité de l'expression de ces
mesures concernant le mali
donc je souhaite plutôt que les
questions que nous poserons ce soir ne
s'oriente pas sur ces sujets on aura
amplement la possibilité pas plus tard
que la semaine prochaine puisque je
rappelle que la semaine prochaine on a
un débat 50-1 donc chaque groupe pourra
s'exprimer amplement sur les mesures qui
ont été annoncées donc c'est tout ça me
semble assez coordonnés
[Musique]